maybe there's more to learn maybe
there's a next step if I could start
from a blank slate what would I do
I think start you know quick and dirty
to let go of commitments and say no to
things I've done one where I'm like
would get a pie in my face define
instinct to it that can help us get
through that debt even if you dive off
that cliff you're gonna be okay don't
keep doing the same thing over and over
having that trust you can't buy that you
become addicted that's your dopamine
this he's a blogger journalist and
published author he's the creator of a
blog called Zen habits Time magazine
named Zen habits at the top of its list
of the top 25 blogs in 2010 he's Lee
obovata
and here his top 10 rules for success so
actually I had someone Twitter I asked
people like what's the think the one
change that has helped you the most and
one person I really love this bless
because it matches up with mine which is
that he replaced opinions with curiosity
hmm
and I love that because to me a lot of
people get to this point where they
think they know something and when you
think you know something that's one
learning like I've done you're doing
there but if you just think okay I might
know something but let's find out more
maybe it's wrong yeah maybe there's more
to learn maybe there's a next step and
there always is more to learn and so
that's to me if you just start with
curiosity rather than like I think I
know it or I don't need to know it or
there's no way I'm going to know how to
that you know that's that's a much
better place to start and it's how I
like learning new things and trying new
things it's really important to look at
your habits as the if you're a new
entrepreneur or been doing it for a
while I think we we tend to fall into
these routines right um and that routine
is a lot of times if you don't do it
consciously it's a routine that just
just happens to build up over time so
like you might you know be busy checking
Facebook and Twitter and all your stats
and everything else and so that you
develop this routine of quickly checking
through everything online and what that
means is through that's just through
just through building that up overtime
it that routine of checking everything
and what that means is that you don't
have time for the creation the part that
I think for me at least is really
important and so um I think it's good to
sometimes just step back and take a look
at what habits you've created over time
and say what can I do more consciously
what if I could start from a blank slate
what would I do and and start to change
those to build those consciously but
with what I found though is that a lot
of times what we do is we try to
implement an entire system of habits all
at once this new thing that we read
about and and it collapses after a
little while and we go back into our old
habits and one of the problems with that
is that we're actually implementing a
whole series of habits at once and again
if you if you start a new morning
routine you might actually be doing five
to ten different habits one right after
the other and and so you're chaining
them together a bunch of new habits and
that's great for like a week or so and
then it collapses and I've seen that so
many times I've done it myself plenty of
times and that what I found is that
doesn't that's not very effective some
people can make it work but most people
are not going to succeed at that so what
you really want to do is keep doing what
you've been doing that that's going to
keep the boat afloat but if you wanted
to start to make changes start making
little changes one at a time to get
going a lot of people are afraid to like
get started they want to have it perfect
and design and everything like that
I say start you know quick and dirty
just start just start writing posts and
you know the post be as useful as
possible and then help think about what
your readers problems are and help them
solve those problems so don't let that
kind of fear of getting started stop you
just just start we all have the same
amount of time of the day but it's just
we have filled the day up with all these
things that we think we need to do like
a like commitments we've you know one
thing I was coaching soccer because I
thought that was important for him for
my kids I was on the PTA the board of
the PTO when I
kids school and I thought that was
important but I realized that I was
spending time doing stuff with other
people instead of the actual kids so I
realized if I let go those commitments
even though I thought their report I
have time then to actually spend with
people who are report to me so you learn
to let go of commitments and say no to
things so you can say yes to the things
you really want that are really
important to you so I had to
I mean sometimes as simple as like just
an email saying I can't do this anymore
I don't have the time you know and you
feel like you're gonna disappoint people
so you don't want to say no yeah but you
know what I learned
life goes on they figure they figure it
out if you have a group around this
habit change all of a sudden you now
have a whole different environment that
gives you a different feedback system so
if you're gonna if you say you tell your
group and this sei group of people that
you actually care about their opinion
because otherwise you'll just forget
about it but if you care about their
opinion now let's say it's five to ten
people and you say I am going to write
every day before I check email or I'm
gonna pay $10,000 right if you told
people that that you would definitely do
it or you know you you know I've done
one where I've like would get a pie in
my face if I didn't stick to it yes
things like that I'm gonna donate to you
know the political party you don't like
yeah um are you gonna have to eat some
factory-farmed meat or something exactly
something you definitely don't do not
what I do
yeah actually what for my book I you
know you know I'm a vegan I promise you
and some other friends that I would eat
a beef you know burger not not just a
veggie burger
if I didn't have his book done by the
end of the year yeah and so I was
motivated to get up and start writing
but anyway so commit to this group
create a consequence that you definitely
are not going to - you don't you don't
want to have and you're definitely not
going to fail and so when you do the
habit you get the positive benefit of
getting to report back to them and even
as you do the heavier thing you know I
get to tell Corbett that I'm gonna do
this yep
I did this and so that's positive
feedback for doing it and then if you
didn't do it you have negative feedback
I'd have to tell your group that I
didn't do it and that would be shameful
and you don't want look bad in the eyes
of your peers and you probably have to
you know eat the burger or get the pie
in the face and so you wouldn't want to
do that so now you've just reversed the
feedback loop with that very simple
change in your environment so I think
you know a lot of times we have a dip in
motivation and if we have a purpose that
can help us get through that dip and it
also helps guide us as we like because
there's there's tons of decisions that
we have to make like on a daily basis
and over the long term and if you have
some kind of purpose that kind of gives
you a little bit of a compass and that
has helped me tremendously in the last
seven eight years since I've been doing
this even if you're just starting out
you haven't gotten to that place where
you're like all confident you're in this
place where you're like you're in this
little comfort zone you know what you're
doing and you don't want to venture out
or maybe you've gotten that confidence
and then you hit that cliff or that door
that's like really scary and what do you
do then and what you've developed and I
think what I've developed too is just
it's not a confidence that I know
everything but a confidence that even if
you dive off that cliff you're gonna be
okay yeah and that's I think that's
really the crucial thing is learning it
doesn't matter if I fail it doesn't
matter if I don't know anything it
doesn't matter if I you know stumble
around in the darkness not knowing what
I'm doing I'll be okay that and there's
really I mean that's the confidence that
you need you know my story back in 2005
when I was stuck with all these bad
habits and I couldn't make any changes I
kept trying to change them all at once I
would change my entire diet which diet
is actually a series of habits I would
change my entire exercise routine I
would try and quit smoking try and be
productive and stop procrastinating wake
up early and I would do all of these at
once and I kept failing I couldn't
understand why and it wasn't really that
it was me you know a lot of times I
would internalize it actually all the
time I would internalize it and think I
haven't
self-control not discipline I'm not good
enough not strong and this week and so I
just feel bad about myself and develop
this negative self-image and basically
destroy any trust that I had in myself
but really it wasn't a problem with me
it was a problem with the method mm-hmm
and so what I'm what I'm proposing is
instead of failing over and over at
creating a whole bunch of habits at once
or one really big habit instead of a
small one instead of failing at that
change the method and yeah I mean if you
failed don't keep doing the same thing
over and over you gotta make some
changes and so what I'm proposing is
take that failure as a lesson and adapt
your habit change and be smarter do it
do it in a smarter way this image this
public image that we try and create
either for ourselves or for our business
I mean it's not real first of all the
second of all if you let that image
crumble and have cracks and stuff and
show the honest reality of things that
people like that I grain and what and
they start to trust you because you're
honest and what you and I know is that
that trust is more valuable than
anything else it's more valuable than
getting a click to subscribe or share or
buy you know having that trust you can't
buy that and the only thing you can do
is be trustworthy and be honest and be
real and if you have this veneer of this
public image that you have and I'm free
to declare here but hoping other people
will hear it is you know that is fake
and people can sense that people have
intuition about whether this person is
just giving you a marketing pitch or if
they're giving you the real deal and if
you give them the real deal they start
to trust you because they know you're
sincere you're not just trying to you
know get their money which most people
are trying to do online and if you are
one of the few who aren't you set
yourself apart as trustworthy honest
sincere and someone who is is there to
genuinely help them
you
you just you're you become addicted
that's your dopamine this yes and so
like I'm totally addicted to helping
people change their lives through habits
through mindfulness and all these other
things that I've been working on but I
don't think that I have done all my work
on that yet I think there's a lot that I
have to learn about helping people I
think there's a lot of people out there
who haven't reached yet so that really
is what gets me up in the morning thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Harold Kuhn asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Leo's
top ten rules meant the most to you
leave it in the comments and I'll join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon